President Trump may be close to turning
in his homework essentially to the
special council president says he has
completed a list of questions from
investigators and he says he did it
himself
of course Donna Richardson reports from
the White House tonight President Trump
claims he has personally finished
answering Special Counsel Robert
Muller's questions that didn't take very
long to film and they were my answers I
don't need lawyers to do that now you
need lawyers for submitted lawyers to go
over some of the answers at an oval
office bill signing the president also
says he's hearing the Moller
investigation will end soon I'm sure
it'll be just fine and you know why it's
going to be just fine because there was
no collusion again describing the
special counsels investigation as a
witch-hunt the president tweeted of
Muller and his team quote they are
screaming and shouting at people
horribly threatening them to come up
with the answers they want they are a
disgrace to our nation and don't care
how many lives they ruin when asked this
afternoon what specifically prompted
that outburst the president says it's
just the continuation of the Muller
investigation which he says should have
never happened
acting Attorney General Matthew Whitaker
now oversees that probe before taking
that job he was critical of the special
counsel some congressional Republicans
are pushing the White House to soon
submit an attorney general nominee and I
think a lot of the questions involving
mr. Whitaker and the Acting AG could be
eliminated if we had a nominee and my
understanding is the White House is
starting to look into that and
but I don't have any as I told you this
morning don't have any indication of
time line or who the candidates are
senator Cornyn says he suspects a
commitment to protect Muller's
investigation will be front and center
during the nominees confirmation hearing
once the president submits his written
answers to the special counsel it's
unclear what happens next indictments
are evidence against those close to the
president or information damaging enough
Democrats push impeachment through the
house though if Muller's report falls
short of more indictments or strong
indications of collusion House Democrats
would have to weigh whether impeachment
is worth the risk
given the political consequences of the
last presidential impeachment a source
tells Fox News the president did not
submit his answers today to the special
counsel also at the White House this
afternoon the president announced he is
nominating Andrew wheeler as his
administrator to the Environmental
Protection Agency wheeler is acting in
that role now but jetson live in the
North Lawn rich thank you